I'm gonna use
everything in my power
to make your life miserable
until you stop doing what you're doing.
I've never seen this
happen before in Australia.
- There has been ongoing conflict.
- They're a YouTube phenomenon.
It was f*****g game over.
This is the future
of Australian hip-hop right here.
Growing up,
we've always had run-ins with police.
They just look at us like criminals.
Where we're trying
to divert kids from violence,
this group was using lyrics
of inciting the acts of violence.
Bro, this video is lit as f**k.
Guess growing up around it,
we got sucked into it.
Violence becomes the means
for you to achieve a status.
There's nothing unique
about art that talks about violence.
But for some reason, when it comes to hip-hop,
we're having that debate all over again.
And I think it's because
of who's telling that story.
If you're constantly
being profiled by police,
and you feel insecure and unsafe
in your own community,
you're gonna get angry.
The real controversial aspect of ONEFOUR
definitely became a double-edged sword.
It's like this yin and yang.
You have the street,
and then you have the music.
We start to see the violence escalate
with these street gangs.
Lekks, my little brother,
and Celly got locked up.
P got four years.
Lekks got four years, and Celly got ten.
I thought like, "How are we gonna be able
to hold up the crew while they're gone?"
They were just starting
to turn their lives around.
And then they're back in trouble
with the police again.
One thing I want people to understand,
is how important it is to
find something you love
and then run with it.
That's the one thing that helped us
get out of a lot of the bulls**t
we had to go through.
We knew that the police were gonna try
to do whatever they could to disrupt.
We had no idea, like, to
what lengths they would go to.
The way that the police are
being used to target ONEFOUR
is something that has
never been seen in Australia.
Where we have a problem,
we are lawfully harassing that group,
and we don't apologise for that.
But is the New South Wales
police an adequate judge
of what is acceptable and what's not?
Hip-hop is the biggest genre in the world.
And yet, we wanna deplatform it and censor it.
If the police are successful
in destroying a group,
it's a dark day for Australia
and freedom of expression.
You know,
there's a lot more to lose if you lose,
so we can't lose.
If that's your thing,
it's gonna keep you out of trouble,
keep you busy
so you're not on the streets,
I'm good with that.